the five point eight magnitude quakes
epicenter was close to the city of Mir
poor in pakistan-administered Kashmir
dozens of homes were destroyed and cars
damaged when roads collapsed in many
areas
Kamal Hyder is in Mir poor that's close
to the epicenter of the earthquake the
first light here in Mid pool which is
situated in Pakistan he administered
Kashmir because the earthquake happened
in the evening of the rescue and relief
operations were hampered by the dark
electricity of course cut off to many
areas cell phone services also disrupted
but the military is now aiding the
civilian government in the rescue
efforts twenty-five people have been
killed hundreds more have been injured
and are under treatment in various
hospitals the Pakistani military is
confident that the situation is under
control and that they will be able to
contain the situation by evening today
so indeed a rescue efforts underway but
what we have been able to witness and
that the people of this area spent their
nights outdoors because of fear that
their homes and buildings may collapse
on them and of course the most of them
decided to sleep outside as you can see
the efforts are still underway to try
and restore key link roads which have
been cut off telecommunication services
have also been disrupted and the
military is now confident to say that
they will be able to contain the
situation
within the next 24 hours